Hey this is Presh Talwalkar. A single alien lands on Earth. Every day after that each
alien on Earth undergoes a transformation, which could be any of the four equally likely events.
The alien could die.
The alien could do nothing.
The alien could replicate itself, which
means there are two aliens in total.
Or, the alien could replicate itself two
times, which means there are three aliens total.
What is the probability the alien
race eventually dies out and goes extinct?
This question is sometimes asked as an
interview question for technical jobs.
Can you figure it out? Give this problem
a try
and when you're ready keep watching the
video for the solution.
Let's write "p" for the probability that an alien and all of
its descendants die out.
The probability that one alien and all of its
descendants die out is "p".
The next day there are four equally likely events.
There's a 25% chance
that this alien could die out. This means
there's a conditional probability of 1
that this alien and all of its
descendants die out. There is another
contingency where the alien does nothing.
Now the situation is exactly the same.
This means the probability is still "p"
that this alien and all of its
descendants will die out. There is also a
25% chance the alien
will replicate itself so that there are
two aliens. Now each of these aliens will
have a probability "p" that this alien and
all of its descendants will die out. Each
of these lines of aliens will be
independent from each other.
The probability that both of them die
and all of their descendants die out will
be the product "p" times "p" equals "p"
squared.
In the final 25% case, the alien replicates itself two times. Each of these aliens has a probability "p" of
dying out and having all of their
descendants die out. Each of these
branches is independent from each other.
The probability that all three die out
will be equal to "p" times "p" times "p"which is "p" cubed.
If the probability is to exist, it must satisfy the following equation.
The probability of an alien and all of its descendants dying out
has to be equal to 0.25 times the quantity 1 + "p" + "p squared" + "p cubed".
In the theory of statistical branching processes, the probability of extinction is equal to the smallest
positive root of this equation. This is
equal to the square root of 2 - 1,
which is approximately 41.4% and that's the
answer. Now to be comprehensive, we should
consider the other solutions to this
equation. One solution is negative and
that can be disregarded because the
probability cannot be negative, but the
other solution is equal to 1. This would
mean there's a probability of 1 that
it's surely going to happen that the
aliens will go extinct.
How do we know that this is not the
solution, and that the correct solution
is 41.4 percent? To figure that out we
have to dig deeper into the details and
consider the discrete version of the
problem. Let's write p sub k for the
probability of an alien and all of its
descendants dying out
in k days. Let's consider the
probability that an alien dies out in k
plus 1 days. There are four things that
can happen the next day.
There's a twenty-five percent chance the
alien dies out in which case the
conditional probability of dying out in
k plus 1 days is equal to 1.
There's a twenty-five percent chance the
alien does nothing. Now one day has
already passed so in order for this
alien and all of its descendants to die
out in k plus 1 days, the next day this
alien and all of its descendants would
have to die out
in k days, it would have to be one day
less. The conditional probability here is
p sub k. In the twenty-five percent
chance the alien replicates itself so
there are two aliens, each of these
aliens and all of their descendants
would have to die out in k days.
This is a conditional probability of p
sub k squared. In the final case the
alien replicates itself two times and
each of these aliens and have a p sub k
chance that that alien and all
the descendants would die out in k days.
The probability of all of them dying out
would be the product which is p sub k cubed.
Now one thing to notice here
is that the expected number of aliens
the next day is equal to 0 + 1 + 2 + 3
all divided by 4 this is equal to 1.5
which is greater than 1, that means the
alien is more than replicating itself on
average, so we can expect that there's a
chance the aliens would survive; the
probability of extinction should not be
equal to 1 it should be less than 1. So
how do we know this is true? We have this
recursive equation for the probability
the alien dies out in k plus 1 days in
terms of the probability that it would
die out in k days. We're going to show
that this probability is always less
than or equal to the square root of
2 - 1. Now what's the probability
an alien would die out in exactly one
day?
Well that's only the 25%
chance that it simply dies out in the
following day.
This is our base case. Now we assume this
is true for all values less than or equal [I correct myself to say] less than p sub k + 1.
So we have this recurrence relation and
we can now apply the induction
hypothesis on all the terms p sub k. So we'll substitute in square root
of 2 - 1 for those terms, and this
all simplifies to be square root of
2 - 1. So we have an increasing
sequence of p sub k because the
probability keeps increasing as we
expand the number of days.
This is an increasing sequence and we
know it's bounded by square root of
2 - 1, so in fact this sequence
will converge to the value of
square root of 2 - 1, and that in
fact is the correct answer to this problem.
Did you figure it out? Thanks for
watching this video, please subscribe to
my channel I make videos on math and
game theory. You can catch me on my blog
Mind Your Decisions which you can follow
on Facebook, Google+, and Patreon. You can
catch me on social media @preshtalwalkar. And if you liked this video please
check out my books through links in the video
description.